[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Marietta Slomka guten Abend
allein die Erdbeben haben schon
furchtbare folgen aber hinzu kommt ja
auch noch dass es in der Region gerade
bitterkalt ist viele Orts liegt Schnee
und es trifft insbesondere auf der
syrischen Seite viele Kriegsflüchtlinge
Menschen die eh schon alles verloren
hatten und unter erbärmlichen
Bedingungen lebten und jetzt auch noch
zehntausende Tote und Verletzte Chaos
und Zerstörung es ist ein grau Laura
zusammengetragen welche Informationen
und Bilder uns bislang erreichen
Bilder aus dem Epizentrum
kachermann-marash knapp 80 km entfernt
von der 2 Millionenstadt Gaziantep
unweit der syrischen Grenze mit einer
Stärke von 7,8 ist die Zerstörungskraft
des Bebens verheerend
die Erdstöße waren gewaltig wir sind
sofort rausgerannt dann haben wir
angefangen unseren engsten
Familienangehörigen und Freunde zu
suchen wir haben viele Menschen verloren
viele können wir nicht erreichen wir
müssen Menschen Bergen von da drüben
kommen die Stimmen von zwei
verschütteten die Such und
Rettungstrupps arbeiten auf Hochtouren
allein auf der türkischen Seite sind
mindestens
1762 Menschen ums Leben gekommen teilte
der katastrophenschutzdienst erfasst mit
mehr als 11.000 sein verletzt worden
bereits in der Nacht hatte die Erde
heftig gebebt
im Moment sind im hinteren Gebäude noch
vermisste Personen begraben ein Freund
von mir hat seine Kinder noch retten
können aber was mit den anderen im
Gebäude ist das wissen wir nicht
der türkische Präsident Erdogan
verspricht schnelle hilfe Hallo
betroffenen Region und in Ankara alles
Erforderliche in die Wege geleitet
derzeit sind 9000 Einsatzkräfte vor Ort
um die Arbeiten engmaschig durchzuführen
wir hoffen dass wir diese Katastrophe
mit möglichst wenigen Opfern überstehen
laut türkischen Behörden werden die
Opferzahlen wohl noch erheblich steigen
man habe zudem die Alarmstufe 4
ausgerufen und damit auch um
internationale Hilfe gebeten betroffen
vor allem der Südosten des Landes der in
weiten Teilen von Kurden besiedelt wird
so wie der Nordwesten Syriens
im Bürgerkriegsland Syrien sind ganze
Siedlungen durch das Erdbeben
ausgelöscht worden vor Ort suchen
Rettungsteams der syrischen weißhelme
nach Vermissten
unsere Teams versuchen sie zu retten
versuchen die Menschen zu retten alle
Menschen mit allen Mitteln aus den
Trümmern zu holen
oft kommt jedoch jede Hilfe zu spät
[Applaus]
überall fehlt es an Geräten zur Bergung
die Hilfstruppen sind noch nicht bis in
alle Teile der betroffenen Regionen
vorgedrungen
ich warte darauf meinen Bruder und seine
Familie ihn und seine sieben Kinder
herauszuholen sie haben jemanden
herausgezogen aber das waren sie nicht
jeder versucht seine Leute zu retten
möge Allah und helfen
im Katastrophengebiet in dem Millionen
Bürgerkriegsflüchtlinge Schutz gesucht
haben herrschen Temperaturen um den
Gefrierpunkt in Syrien kamen nach
Angaben des Gesundheitsministeriums
mindestens 1300 Menschen ums Leben
ja und aus dem türkischen Erdbebengebiet
aus Gaziantep ist uns Jesko Weikert
zugeschaltet von der Welthungerhilfe
erarbeitet dort als
nothilfekoordinator in der Region guten
Abend Herr Weikert
sie haben dieses Erdbeben ja am eigenen
Leib erlebt
genau ich bin heute morgen aufgewacht
von einem wackelnden Zimmer ja Sachen
aus dem aus dem Regal gefallenen Bücher
umgefallen
das hat auch sehr lange gedauert also
ich schätze mal eine Minute ich habe
immer gedacht das wird ja gleich aus und
Erdbeben dauert ja nicht lange aber dann
ging es immer weiter und ja ich habe
erst gar nicht realisiert was das jetzt
eigentlich bedeutet und war und habe
dann erst irgendwie beim durch die Stadt
laufen und durch die Nachrichten von den
Kolleginnen und Kollegen einfach gemerkt
was das für ein Erdbeben war und was das
für Folgen hatte ihr Haus steht nun
immerhin noch also Sie haben ja noch ein
Dach über dem Kopf aber wie sieht das in
ihrer Nachbarschaft aus
die in Gaziantep stehen die Häuser in
der Regel noch aber die Menschen trauen
sich halt nicht darin zu schlafen weil
das sind alles so riesen Apartmenthäuser
drei vier fünf Stockwerke hoch und die
haben halt teilweise Risse und
deswegen trauen sich die Menschen
einfach nicht mehr rein also auch ne es
gab heute Nachmittag noch mal ein
richtig heftiges nachgeben auch mit ähm
über sieben auf der Skala und dann sind
die Leute rein Weise panisch aus dem
Häusern gerannt ja weil sie halt die
Bilder auch aus anderen Orten gesehen
haben wo eben dann noch Gebäude
zusammengestürzt sind und
dementsprechend die in Großteil meiner
Kolleginnen und Kollegen schlagen heute
Nacht entweder im Auto ist oder in
irgendwelchen kommunalen Unterkünften
also Schulen Universität
Moschee weil sie sich einfach nicht in
ihre Gebäude reintragen
dann ist auf türkischer Seite ja die die
Hilfe angelaufen und es ist Hilfe
unterwegs und es wird untersucht nach
Verschütteten aber Sie kennen sich ja
auch in Syrien aus sie waren ja auch mit
der Betreuung von Flüchtlingen befasst
wie muss man sich das dort vorstellen
dass das ist ja da ist das Schlimmste zu
befürchten
ja in
Syrien gibt es bisher weit weniger Tote
zu beklagen als in der Türkei aber auch
da sind halt zahlreiche Gebäude
zusammengestürzt in Syrien ist die
ist quasi die das Hilfssystem einfach
etwas improvisiertierter nur muss man
sich das so vorstellen dass leiden hat
12 Jahre Bürgerkrieg in den Gebieten in
denen wir arbeiten hat sich quasi die
die Nothilfe der syrischen Bevölkerung
selber organisiert das heißt da gibt es
diese auch relativ bekannten white
Thermomix die dann quasi wie in
Deutschland das THW versuchen die Leute
aus den aus dem Gebäuden rauszuholen
rauszubekommen oder eben einfach mit
einer wesentlich schlechteren
Infrastruktur und viel schlechteren
Ausstattung als es halt in der Türkei
der Fall ja wir hören ja auch dass sie
da zum Teil gar keine Geräte haben also
weiß Helme die sich dazu entsprechen
jetzt bei Ihnen die Rettungsarbeiten im
Moment noch weiter ist es ja jetzt auch
nicht sowieso nur eiskalt sondern auch
stockdunkel
wie gesagt passiert nicht so viel weil
ich habe einen wirklich
zusammengefallenes Gebäude gesehen sonst
ist es eben dass die Gebäude eher
beschädigt sind ich weiß weil wir noch
im Büro haben das ist ein Hatay das ist
in der Provinz am Mittelmeer das ist
viel stärker betroffen da ist es so da
ist ist schwer Leute überhaupt
telefonisch zu erreichen das gehen die
aufräumen Arbeiten voran und da ist es
aber auch so dass halt einzelne bei
einzelnen Gebäuden wohl einfach noch
keine Helfer da sind und ja die
Familienmitglieder die dann an den
Häusern stehen sind verzweifelt und
warten darauf dass jemand kommt und
ihnen hilft also da ist wirklich ein
hartei ist offensichtlich das System
komplett überfordert weil das wirklich
ähm wohl die schlimmste Katastrophe seit
1939 ist also das ist mein wie gesagt
man kann sich das von der
die massiv das ist und wie viele Leute
das betrifft wirklich nicht vorstellen
danke für diese Informationen direkt aus
der Türkei
guten Abend
das Gespräch haben wir vorhin
aufgezeichnet für Geologen ist diese
Katastrophe keine Überraschung dass sie
leider an den Zeitpunkt wann es dort
wieder besonders schwere Erschütterungen
gibt nicht vorhersagen können aber das
die Region hochgefährdet ist wusste man
natürlich ein so verheerendes Leben gab
es jedoch lange nicht genau genommen war
die Erde aus geologischer Sicht dort
sogar zu lange zu ruhig nun sprechen
Fachleute bereits von einem
Jahrhundertbeben Hintergründe dazu von
Christiane Hoffmann
Leid Trauer Zerstörung
verzweifelte Rettungsversuche nicht nur
ein Beben sondern dutzende erschütterten
die türkisch-syrische Grenzregion den
ganzen Tag lang das erste morgens viert
in Karaman Maras mit einer Stärke von
7,8 und dann in den Nachbarregionen
gassian Tape und malatia
danach gab es sehr viele weitere
Erdbeben mindestens mit Magnitude 4 aber
auch ein oder zwei Ereignisse die mit
Magnitude 7 und größer weiter
aufgetreten sind das heißt das ganze
System dort geodynamisch zwischen
anatolischer und arabischer Platte ist
noch nicht zur Ruhe gekommen die ganze
Region ist der schüttert denn sie liegt
am Rand gleich mehrere Erdplatten die
sich in unterschiedliche Richtungen
bewegen so schiebt die arabische Platte
die anatolische nach Westen 2,5 cm im
Jahr sie drücken gegeneinander verhaken
sich wird dann die Spannung zu groß
entstehen Brüche und Erschütterungen
immer wieder gibt es deshalb schwere
Erdbeben das tödlichste der letzten 100
Jahre im Dezember 1939
33.000 Menschen starben ähnlich stark
bebte die Erde 1999
17.000 Menschen kamen ums Leben mehr als
100.000 wurden obdachlos
zuletzt wurde die Region vor drei Jahren
erschüttert die Provinz elasee 41
Menschen kamen ums Leben die Schäden und
Opfer jetzt dürften um einiges höher
liegen denn die Erde bebte
vergleichsweise nahe unter der
Erdoberfläche und großflächig
daraus können wir in etwa die
Bruchfläche von ca 200 Kilometern
abschätzen im Untergrund die gerissen
ist in dieser Region hat es etwa seit
1000 Jahren kein so großes Beben mehr
gegeben das heißt wissenschaftlich
gesehen haben wir sozusagen fast damit
gerechnet dass dort auch wieder ein
starkes Ereignis auftreten muss
offenbar ein Ausnahme Beben und es
trifft die Menschen mitten im Winter
auch deshalb ist die Rettung von
verschütteten noch mal mehr ein Wettlauf
gegen die Zeit
und über die Situation den betroffenen
Gebieten wollen wir noch sprechen mit
unserer reporterin Anne brüllen Istanbul
und unserer Korrespondentin für den
arabischen Raum culine Abtei schauen wir
erst nach Istanbul an die Türkei hat ja
nun bekanntermaßen große
erdbebengefährdete Gebiete aber man hat
dann offenbar doch nicht damit gerechnet
dass es in der Region wieder so schlimm
kommt
naja allein durch die geographische Lage
rechnet man hier natürlich mit Erdbeben
aber dies das ist diesmal kam es
wirklich sehr schlimm wie schlimm das
lässt vielleicht eine Äußerung des
türkischen Präsidenten Erdogan erahnen
der vom schwersten Beben seit mehr als
80 Jahren gesprochen hat
eingeschlossen ist da auch dieses Beben
wir haben es den Beitrag gehört 1999 in
ist mit mit 17.000 Toten diesmal
scheinen also die türkischen Behörden
davon auszugehen dass es noch höhere
Opferzahlen geben wird dazu kommt dass
eine wirklich riesige Region betroffen
ist zehn Provinzen im Südosten des
Landes mit vielen großen Städten
gaziante die aber hier gehören dazu und
die Rettungsarbeiten die laufen
natürlich auch in dieser Nacht weiter
insgesamt sind 10.000 Rettungskräfte
auch jetzt noch im Einsatz das haben die
Behörden gerade gesagt die ersten 72
Stunden sind ja entscheidend wenn es um
die Hilfe für verschüttete geht
es gibt immer wieder Nachbeben viele
Brücken Straßen Flughäfen sind auch
zerstört das macht es schwer für weitere
Rettungsteams überhaupt in die Region zu
gelangen dazu kommt das schlechte Wetter
es schneit es regnet bei Temperaturen um
den Gefrierpunkt viele Überlebende
müssen diese Nacht unter diesen
Umständen draußen im Freien verbringen
und die warten natürlich sehnlichst auf
Hilfe das türkische Militär hat eine
luftschutzbrücke eingerichtet bringt
Hilfe in die Region Zelte warme
deckenhöfen das ist das was neben
schwerem Gerät gerade am meisten
gebraucht wird und das wird die Frage
auf golini wer in den syrischen Gebieten
hilft also eigentlich bräuchten die ihr
dort ausgerechnet Hilfe von den Akteuren
von denen dort viele geflohen sind also
vom syrischen Regime
ja in den Gebieten die von Machthaber
Bashar alle Assad aus Damaskus
kontrolliert werden hilft der syrische
Halbmond bestehen noch staatliche
Strukturen wenn auch rudimentär wenn
auch die Infrastruktur und die Logistik
sehr beeinträchtigt ist aber es gibt
Hilfe vom russischen
Katastrophenschutzministerium vom
Verbündeten Iran das wird wahrscheinlich
auch materielle Hilfen geben von den
Verbündeten in Algerien oder den
Emiraten aber die wirtschaftliche Lage
der Bevölkerung dort ist sehr schlecht
ich rechne mit wirklich enormen Folgen
auch für die Menschen dort und die Lage
in Nordwest Syrien das nicht unter der
Kontrolle von Assad ist diese Lage ist
eigentlich fatal ähm das Gebiet war
vorher schon eine humanitäres
Krisengebiet es hat sehr viel Zerstörung
gegeben durch sehr regelmäßige russische
Angriffe ich habe jetzt gerade ein Bild
gesehen von einem Krankenhaus in dem
wirklich die Toten in den Fluren sich
stapeln also es ist wirklich eine massiv
betroffen verschiedene Region und im
Grunde helfen dort können sich nur Syrer
gegeneinander also
zusammenhelfen Syrer helfen Syrern es
gibt 3000 weißhelme die aber nur
begrenzte treibstoffreserven haben und
die wirklich nur begrenzt helfen können
weil sie auch kein schweres Gerät haben
das heißt wenn jetzt international die
Hilfe nicht entschieden anläuft dann
bedeutet das für die Menschen dort
nichts Gutes weder für die Verschütteten
die noch leben noch für die Überlebenden
die jetzt auf den Straßen und auf den
Feldern sind und dort übernachten
keine guten Aussichten danke euch beiden
nach Istanbul und Kairo
und wenn sie den Menschen im
Erdbebengebiet helfen wollen können Sie
spenden beim Aktionsbündnis
Katastrophenhilfe die IBAN
de6500-400 600-100 400 600 Stichwort ZDF
Erdbeben Türkei Syrien
Informationen gibt es auch unter
spenden.zdf.de oder im ZDF Text auf
Seite 890
der chinesische Ballon über dem Himmel
der USA ist zwar abgeschossen zieht aber
politisch weiter Kreise und damit geht
es jetzt bei dir weiter Heinz ja die
Bundesregierung hat sich besorgt gezeigt
man hoffe dass der Vorfall nicht zu
weiteren Spannungen bzw eine Eskalation
im amerikanischen chinesischen
Verhältnis führen werde sagte ein
Regierungssprecher in Berlin in den USA
läuft die Bergung der Trümmerteile für
eine weitere Untersuchung
Bundeswirtschaftsminister Harbeck ist in
Washington ein zentrales Thema seiner
Gespräche dort dürfte das
us-inflationsbekämpfungsgesetz sein dass
milliardenschwere Investitionen in den
Klimaschutz vorsieht in Europa fürchtet
man Nachteile für heimische Unternehmen
vor den Gesprächen morgen äußerte sich
habe am Abend
für die Batterie und Automobilhersteller
ist das denke ich ein wichtiger Schritt
aber wir müssen eben andere Bereiche
auch noch sehen die dadurch nicht
erfasst sind das ist der Ausbau von
erneuerbaren Energien die Produktion von
einer erbaren Energien die Frage wie wir
Rohstoffe nicht gegeneinander und
sichern sondern vielleicht in einer Art
Rohstoff Partnerschaft eine grüne Brücke
mit der Atlantik schlagen können also es
zeigt wo ein Wille ist findet man noch
einen Weg und der Wille ist glaube ich
erkennbar groß von beiden Seiten ein
paar Wege müssen noch gefunden werden
das Bundesinnenministerium hat die Pläne
für einen neuen flüchtlingsgipfel
konkretisiert den Ministerin Fräser
angekündigt hat er solle innerhalb der
nächsten zwei bis drei Wochen
stattfinden teilte ein Sprecher mit der
deutsche Landkreistag forderte
Unterstützung aus dem Kanzleramt
kreistag-präsident sage erklärte die
Kapazitäten seien viele Orts erschöpft
und das erforderliche Geld dazu viele
auch
beide Deutschen Post sind laut
Gewerkschaft wäre die auch am Dienstag
bundesweite Warnstreiks geplant dennoch
sind rund 8000 Postbedienstete dem
Streik Aufruf am heutigen Montag gefolgt
für rund 160.000 Tarifbeschäftigte soll
es 15 Prozent mehr Lohn geben der
Postvorstand wie ist diese Forderung als
unrealistisch zurück insgesamt hielten
sich die Auswirkungen des Streiks nach
Unternehmensangaben aber zunächst in
Grenzen
Großbritannien erlebt der nationale
Gesundheitsdienst nhls den größten
Streik seiner knapp 75-jährigen
Geschichte nach Gewerkschaftsangaben
streiken zehntausende Pflege und
Rettungskräfte für bessere
Arbeitsbedingungen und eine Anpassung
der Gehälter an die Inflation die
konservative Regierung zeigte bislang
kein Entgegenkommen und kritisierte die
Grundversorgung könnte gefährdet sein
die ist laut Gewerkschaften aber
sichergestellt
[Applaus]
so oft kann man auf dieser Welt Menschen
für ihren Mut bewundern etwa für den Mut
sein eigenes Leben zu riskieren um gegen
Diktaturen aufzustehen wie derzeit zum
Beispiel im Iran was sich die jungen
Frauen und Männer dort trauen wohl
wissend was ihn blüht wenn sie verhaftet
werden Folter Vergewaltigung Hinrichtung
woher nehmen Menschen diese Kraft warum
schaffen das manche und andere nicht und
wie würde man sich selbst verhalten die
Frage kann man sich auch immer wieder
stellen wenn man in die deutsche
Vergangenheit blickt die jungen
Studenten aus München und zu einer ihrer
Professoren die es wagten sich gegen den
Nationalsozialismus zu erheben Sex
Mitglieder der Weißen Rose wurden
hingerichtet 80 Jahre ist das nun her
vom heutigen Gedenken an sie berichtet
sie kennen die Geschichte vom Widerstand
der Weißen Rose doch zum ersten Mal sind
diese 12 klässler aus Saarburg bei Trier
an dem Ort an dem die Mitglieder dieses
studentischen Freundeskreises agierten
hier im Lichthof der
Ludwig-Maximilians-Universität
verteilten die Geschwister Scholl am 18
februar 1943 ihre Flugblätter mit dem
Aufruf zum Widerstand gegen die
Nationalsozialisten die sind schon ein
Vorbild weil es hätten ich glaube ich
hätte fast niemand von ich werde das
jetzt glaube ich auch nicht gemacht mein
Leben zu riskieren oder in dieser Angst
zu leben erwischt zu werden der überlegt
man auch ein bisschen mehr wieso die das
überhaupt gemacht haben und diesen Mut
hatten sich dem zu stellen und die
Flugblätter von oben runter zu schmeißen
die 21-Jährige Sophie Scholl ihr zwei
Jahre älterer Bruder Hans und der
gemeinsame Freund Christoph Probst
wurden bei der Flugblattaktion erwischt
und vier Tage später hingerichtet
Bundespräsident Steinmeier würdigt heute
an der Münchner Universität den
Widerstand der Mitglieder der Weißen
Rose und ruft auf zum wehrhaften Einsatz
für die Demokratie ihr Kampf für Frieden
Freiheit und Menschenwürde
ihr Appell an jede und jeden einzelnen
Verantwortung zu übernehmen das ist
ihr Vermächtnis und damit eben auch Ihr
Auftrag an uns die wir heute in der
Demokratie leben mit dabei Wolfgang
Huber auch sein Vater der Münchner
Universitätsprofessor kurt Huber wurde
1943 hingerichtet er hatte das letzte
Flugblatt der Weißen Rose gegen das
Nazi-Regime mit verfasst Steinmeier sei
es gelungen den Bogen zu schlagen in die
Gegenwart ich fand sehr gut dass er
darauf eingegangen ist dass Teile
unserer Verfassung als Antwort auf die
Diktatur der Nazizeit zu verstehen ist
also die Formulierung unserer
Freiheitsrecht der speziell das
Widerstandsrecht
auch Alexander Schmorell wurde als
Mitglied der Weißen Rose 1943
hingerichtet sein Neffe Markus Schmorell
trifft die Schülerinnen und Schüler aus
Saarburg in der denkstätte weiße Rose an
der Münchner Uni das sein Onkel heute
als Held des Widerstandes geehrt wird
macht ihn stolz doch das war nicht immer
so erzählt er
meine Großeltern waren
zuerst einmal in der Breite der
Bevölkerung
Eltern von Verrätern
in welchem Klima der Angst und
Unterdrückung die Freunde der Weißen
Rose damals ihren Protest wagten und mit
welcher unerbitterlichen Härte die Nazi
Schergen gegen sie vorgingen auch das
erfahren die jungen Leute in der
denkstätte weiße Rose der Frieden ist
kein Selbstverständlichkeit
sehen sondern wir müssen für den Frieden
uns einsetzen und auch aktiv dafür
wirken dass der Frieden erhalten bleibt
die Flugblätter der Widerstandsgruppe
weiße Rose galten 1943 als schwerster
Fall hochverräterischer Propaganda dafür
bezahlten die Mitglieder damals mit
ihrem Leben heute gibt es höchstes Lob
für den Widerstand der Geschwister
Scholl und ihrer Freunde
und jetzt noch mal Heinz mit dem Blick
auf die Wirtschaft für die deutsche
Industrie gab es zum Ende des letzten
Jahres im Dezember ein deutliches
Auftrags plus jedenfalls im Vergleich
zum Vormonat November im Vergleich zum
Vorjahr war es im Dezember dagegen ein
Minus Frank Bethmann was lässt sich
daraus ableiten wo steht die deutsche
Industrie ja tatsächlich wird gerade
darum gerungen ist das Wasserglas
bereits wieder halb voll oder doch noch
halb leer weil es im Dezember gut lief
beispielsweise Maschinenbau aber auch in
der Metallverarbeitung freut sich die
deutsche Industrie bei den auftragsein
Gegenüber das größte Plus seit über
einem Jahr gegenüber dem Vormonaten
November stiegen die Bestellungen um
3,2% aber anders das Bild betrachtet man
die letzten 12 Monate um über 10% ist
das Volumen seitdem gesunken und so sagt
dann auch jörg Krämer Chef Volkswirt der
Commerzbank das Auftrags Plus im
Dezember ist vor allem eine
Gegenbewegung zum Einbruch im November
der Trend weiß bei den Auftragseingängen
weiter klar nach unten eine Auffassung
die der DAX heute zu teilen Schienen das
Kursbarometer startet schlecht in die
neue Woche verliert heute 130 Punkte
oder 0,8 Prozent dabei gibt es durchaus
auch Mutmacher die deutschen Exporteure
beispielsweise blicken inzwischen so
positiv nach vorne wie lange nicht mehr
sie setzen und hoffen auf einen Comeback
Chinas auf einen wirtschaftlichen
Aufschwung im Reich der Mitte Frank
Bethmann vielen Dank
bei der Ski-WM in Frankreich ging es zum
Auftakt heute bei den Damen um die
Kombination für die Gesamtweltcup
führende Mikaela shiffrin wurde es
nichts mit der ersten Medaille sie steht
im Slalom aus gewonnen hat die
Italienerin Federer
Fassungslosigkeit bei Federica Brignone
sie ist die erste Titelträgerin dieser
WM was in meiner Karriere noch gefehlt
hat war eine Goldmedaille und ich bin so
aufgeregt und glücklich über den
heutigen Tag
in der Alpin Kombination fährt die
32-Jährige Italienerin am Morgen im
Super-G von Meribel Bestzeit am
Nachmittag bleibt Union nach einem
überraschend guten Slalom in
Führung dann die Szene des Tages die
große top Favoritin Micaela shiffrin aus
den USA fädelt kurz vor Schluss ein und
scheidet aus Gold verbrennunion Silber
gewinnt wenn die Holdener aus der
Schweiz Bronze die Österreicherin
Amerikaner die einzige deutsche
Teilnehmerin immer Eicher landet am Ende
auf Platz 8
eigentlich hieß die Veranstaltungen Los
Angeles Granny Verleihung man hätte sie
diesmal aber auch umbenennen können in
die Festspiele der Beyoncé mit ihrem 32
Grammy den sie letzte Nacht überreicht
bekam ist sie nunmehr einsamere Vorteil
darin so viele wie sie hat noch keine
Künstlerin oder Künstler gewonnen bei
den diesjährigen Grammys gab es für sie
gleich vier Anlass für eine Oma an Queen
B von Claudia Bates
[Applaus]
heute Nacht wird Geschichte geschrieben
sie bricht den Rekord Beyoncé mit ihrem
Dance Album relations ihr 32 Grammy so
viele hatte niemand vor ihr alles ist
Glamour alles ist Show auch in der
tiefen Bewegtheit des Moments ist kein
Raum für Improvisation
ich möchte Gott danken dass er mich
beschützt danke Gott
ich danke meinem wunderbaren Ehemann und
meinen drei Kindern
[Applaus]
sie bleibt immer in der Rolle der Prop
Diva der sensiblen Kämpferin emotional
aber doch unnahbar
der oder die größte aller Zeiten ist
nicht LeBron nicht Jordan nicht Tom
Brady und nicht Messi es ist Beyoncé
okay
mit ihrem Album habe sie eines faire
schaffen wollen die frei von
Perfektionismus ist sagte sie dabei ist
genau das ihre Spezialität völlige
Makellosigkeit seit Jahrzehnten in
Kirchenchören hat sie begonnen mit 15
der erste Plattenvertrag in den 90ern
Frontfrau der Girl Band Destiny's Child
Solokarriere globaler Ruhm
[Musik]
den sie auch nutzt für ihren politischen
Kampf sie will Frauen helfen Ketten zu
sprengen unterstützt die
Präsidentschaftskandidatur von Hillary
Clinton
[Applaus]
sie ist deine Frau die eine Inspiration
für so viele ist und ich danke dir und
sie dafür dass sie aufsteht und der Welt
zeigt wir sind am stärksten wenn wir uns
umeinander kümmern
[Musik]
sie singt bei der Amtseinführung des
ersten schwarzen US-Präsidenten
und selbst im Moment der Krise der
Untreue ihres Ehemanns erschafft sie aus
Schmerz und Wut ein aggressives
musikalisches Statement für die selbst
Ermächtigung schwarzer Frauen
diese Schnittstelle von Geschlecht und
raste das fühlte sich einfach an wie ein
Hilfspaket für schwarze Frauen
als Musikerin schwebt sie längst über
jeder Politik Queen Bee einer der
größten weiblichen Popstars unserer Zeit
[Applaus]
das war von uns mit dem montagskino
geht's gleich weiter und danach um 23
Uhr meldet sich mit unserem heute schon
mal Update bis morgen auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter bevor wir nach
Deutschland schauen ein Blick in die
Türkei in die Erdbebenregion hier gibt's
noch Regen und Schnee in der Nacht und
das lässt dann in den Frühstunden nach
kalt bleibt es trotzdem dort bei uns
auch kalt und noch ein bisschen
Schneefall vor allem nach Südwesten in
ansonsten bildet sich mit diesem Hoch
teilweise auch Hochnebel ja und das in
der kommende nachts nach Norden gibt es
diesen Hochnebel der ist ziemlich dicht
sonst lockert es auf nach Osten hin und
Südosten Richtung Oberrhein der letzte
Schnee der dann in der nachts nachlässt
und das bei tiefsten Temperaturen
knackig kalt mit 14 Grad im Südosten
minus ein Grad an der Nordsee das ist
die
Temperaturspanne morgen dann viel
Sonnenschein in der Südhälfte und auch
nach Osten hin nach Norden ist noch der
Hochnebel dabei und der löst sich
langsam auf na kommt auch dort die Sonne
raus die Temperaturen erreich größte
Werte von 0 Grad am Alpenrand und sechs
Grad ganz im Westen Richtung Niederrhein
Sonnenschein gibt es weiterhin vor allem
am Mittwoch häufig verbreitet auch nach
Norden hin und der Wind der ist kräftig
aus östlichen Richtungen ist böse und
kann durchaus ruppig sein Temperaturen -
ein bis sieben Grad ähnliche
Temperaturen am Donnerstag ganz im
Norden etwas Regen und Freitag gibt es
auch etwas Schnee dazu und damit ein
schöner Abend